موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
سيطره قواتها بشكل كامل على مدينه سوليدار
شرقيه اوكرانيا واقله الوزاره ان الخطوه
ستسمح بعزل القوات الاوكرانيه في باخموت
وقطع الامدادات عنها واشدت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه بما وصفته شجاعه قوات المجموعه
مؤكدا ان القوات الاوكرانيه لا تزال تدافع
عن مواقعها بالمدينه من جهتها بثت قياده
الاركان الاوكرانيه صورا قالت انها لتصدي
قواتها لمحاولات التسلل لان روسيه في
بخمته واكدتنا جنود هيحافظون على مواقعهم
في المدينه
اعلنها حلفو شمال الاطلسيه انه سيرسل
طيارات استطلاع المترازي اواكس الى
رومانيا الثلاثاء المقبل لمراقبه النشاط
العسكريه الروسي واقل الحلفه انه لا ينبغي
ان يكون هناك شك في عزمه على الدفاع عن كل
شبر من اراضي اعضائه
الا وزير الخارجيه التركيه مولوده شوشو
اوغلو انما وصفه باستهدف انصار حزب العمال
الكردستاني للرئيس التركي خلال مظاهره في
ستوكهولم يعتبر جريمه كراهيه واشار الى ان
السويد كانت قد تعاهدت بمنع حدوث ذلك
وعليها ان تفي بوعودها وفقا تعبيره اذا
كانت تريد الدعم تركيا الانضمام الى نيته
هذا واستنكرت الخارجيه السويديه ثم شهدته
مظاهره مناوئه للرئيس التركي في استقال من
افعال من قبل المحتجين وقالت انها تتفاهم
رد فعل انقره على ذلك وقالت الخارجيه
السويديه في بيان ان منظمه المسؤوله عن
هذا الفعل على صراحه ان هدفها تخرب السويد
الانضمام الى نيته
نقلت صحيفه اورسيت جورنال عن مسؤولين
امريكيين النا اداره البايرن تستعد لطلب
موافقه الكونجرس من اجل بيع طائره اف 16
لتركيا واقل المسؤولون الامريكيون للصحيفه
ان الطلبه الامريكيه مشروطا بموافقه انقره
عن انضمام فنلندا والسويد الى النيتو
اكد الرئيس الامريكي
بالدفاع عن اليابان باستخدام كل قدراتها
بما في ذلك النوويه وقال في بيان المشترك
في ختامي قمه الرئيس
الوزراء الياباني وكل شيء داخل البيت
الابيض قال ان تحالف البلدين سيبقى حجره
زاويه لحفظ الامن والسلام في المحيطين
الهندي
القائم بالقوه او بالاكراه في اي مكان في
العالم
اشكركم على متابعتي هذا الموجز اينما كنتم
طابت اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]